no se presenten sin más en la frontera
quédense donde están y presenten su
solicitud legalmente Desde allí es la
petición que Joe biden hizo a quienes
quieren llegar a Estados Unidos al
tiempo que anunció cambios en la
política migratoria del país desde ahora
otorgará 30.000 permisos humanitarios
mensuales a migrantes de Venezuela
Nicaragua Cuba y Haití pero deben hacer
su solicitud desde otro país
pero esto es importante si las personas
de estos países intentan cruzar las
fronteras estadounidenses sin permiso o
la mexicana o la panameña desde hoy no
serán elegibles para esta vía legal el
mensaje es claro deben quedarse donde
están y aplicar Desde allí
para obtenerlo necesitarán un
patrocinador en territorio
estadounidense pero con el permiso
podrán vivir y trabajar durante dos años
en el país si los solicitantes intentan
cruzar ilegalmente la frontera serán
expulsados y vetados por cinco años para
este nuevo proceso
cambio afecta a toda la región
los retos hemisféricos requieren
soluciones hemisféricas y estamos
trabajando estrechamente con los
gobiernos de toda la región para crear
vías legales
con este fin vaiden viajará el domingo
por primera vez hasta la ciudad del paso
fronteriza con México más tarde en la
semana se reunirá también con el
presidente mexicano Andrés Manuel López
Obrador cuyo país ya se comprometió a
a 30.000 migrantes deportados al
mes